[موسيقى]
لذا استعرض بعض الميزات
الجديدة للبكسل لهذا اليوم ، ما هي
أكبر الوجبات السريعة ، هناك الكثير من
التقنيات في البكسل 4 ، إنه يحتوي على
شريحة رادار جديدة نسميها إحساس الحركة
والتي تتيح لك رؤية الإيماءات وأشياء من
هذا
القبيل أيضًا  لديه مساحة على القفل ، لذا فهو
سيفتح الهاتف بسرعة
والقطع الذي يعملان معًا من أجله بحيث يتم تشغيله
بشكل أسرع ومن ثم بالطبع
أنظمة الكاميرا الجديدة رائعة ، لذا فهي مخصصة
للأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن
أحدث المعجبين بـ Google.
تريد أفضل ما في Google وما نقدمه
حتى يبدو الجزء الخلفي من الجهاز
مشابهًا إلى حد ما لجهاز iPhone ولكنه يزيد بمقدار 100 دولار
عن تكلفة الطراز الأساسي ، كيف
تختار خطة الشركة التميز في
السوق وكيف  تبرير
التكلفة جيدًا أولاً ، نعتقد أنه يقارن
بشكل إيجابي مع جهازي iPhone الأعلى
تكلفة وهما أغلى ثمناً ولدينا أيضًا
منتج pixel 3a وهو رائع
للأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن
هاتف ذكي قوي للغاية  e بميزانية محدودة ، فهي تتمتع
بجميع أعمال الكاميرا الرائعة ولديها أيضًا
إمكانية الوصول إلى مساعد Google ، لذا
فإن الجمع بين الاثنين يمنح الأشخاص
خيارًا رائعًا إذا كانوا يحاولون شراء
هاتف ذكي بميزانية محدودة يبحثون عن
هاتف رائع ثم  تظهر أحدث
التقنيات في pixel
for crock الذي يشبه أفضل البرامج
الرئيسية المتاحة لشخص
مهتم حقًا بمصادر نظام Android
البيئي ، ويقول أن البكسل يستحوذ على
ما يقرب من 1 إلى 2 ٪ من
سوق الهواتف الذكية العالمي اليوم أعلنت الشركة
أن  ستأتي
إلى المزيد من شركات النقل ، هل تأمل أن
يزداد ذلك نوعًا ما ، حيث يتم
تشجيعهم وزيادة النمو والمستخدمين ،
نعم ، أعني أننا نعمل
متحمسين جدًا للإطلاق مع
شركاء اتصالات جدد من الواضح أن هناك أشخاصًا
يرغبون حقًا في الشراء من  الناقل الخاص بهم ،
كما تعلم ، نحن بسبب أعمال الأجهزة ،
لذلك نريد أن نبقى مركزين في
المناطق الجغرافية التي ندعمها ونريد
التأكد من حصولنا على تجربة المستخدم
الصحيحة حقًا  نحن نتوسع
لأن Google تريد الاستمرار في صنع الأجهزة من
الواضح أن تاريخك في البرامج
والخدمات ، فلماذا تستمر في دفع الأجهزة ،
نعم ، أعني أننا شعرنا أن أفضل
طريقة للابتكار لمستخدمينا للأشخاص
الذين أرادوا حقًا أن تكون أحدث
تقنيات Google هي البداية
بناء تجارب شاملة في الوقت الحالي ، أصبحت
صناعة الحوسبة في مكان
يتباطأ فيه قانون مور ، وبالتالي
فهي مكان يتعين عليك فيه تصميم
أنظمة كاملة إذا كنت تريد أن تكون في هذا
التطور ، لذا فنحن نطور أنظمة من
أجل  الأشخاص الذين يرغبون في الحصول على أفضل ما في
Google وأحدث ابتكاراتنا
ولهذا السبب نحن في نهاية المطاف في
لعبة المنتجات النهائية الآن
[موسيقى]